Warren Buffett said that the difference
between really successful people and the
most successful people this is me
paraphrasing is that the most successful
people say no to almost everything it's
so simple and so hard which a lot of
success habits are one of the things
that Layla has been so good at helping
me with and I think a lot of My Success
earlier on was propelled by the fact
that like when I met Laila I had a
chiropractor agency a dental agency five
gym locations a gym launch business
where we did turn arounds I had all of
those things going on and there was no
CEO besides me I mean I made money from
all of them but no income like
everything was just enough to break even
it was nine spinning plates I was so
opportunistic and it's very classic new
entrepreneur to just say yes to
everything